ccsd hoping to draw in more teachers by
increasing starting pay and sending
bonuses to current staff but some feel
the district is missing the mark madison
kimbrough joins us live from the
newsroom with what ccsd teachers are
saying madison yeah well some may see
this as a step in the right direction
after a tumultuous year within the clark
county school district current teachers
expressing their frustration tonight
over the lack of consideration when it
comes to their work and pay
i'm not making
that much more than what brand new
teachers are going to be getting now
and i'm wondering what is the
reason for me to stay in this district
clark county school district is raising
starting teacher paid over 50 thousand
dollars a bump of more than seven
thousand to entice more new hires in
clark county current staff will get
bonuses up to five thousand dollars
lenny leither a teacher at fay herron
elementary calling the news a slap in
the face to those already in the
classroom they could have said hey
inflation is really high this year we
want to make sure that you know you
appreciate it even though it's not new
contract time we're going to give you a
five percent
cost of living raise maria zuniga a
teacher at canyon springs high school
says she's happy the district is
increasing the pay to be more
competitive with other states so we can
fix the teacher shortage here in nevada
but feels that teachers like her who
have worked for the district for years
are now being pushed out we feel
we got the short end and the stick we've
been working hard people have been here
10 15 17 21 25 years they're not getting
anything
we feel left out you know why can't you
take care of the teachers who are
actually staying here
and being loyal to ccsd zuniga stating
that she and her colleagues would prefer
an increase in their actual pay rather
than a one-time bonus that will then get
taxed on
now as for those bonuses for current
staff they will be paid in two parts the
first part coming in september of 2022
then the second coming in may of next
year in the newsroom madison kimbrough
live local now